hey guys and welcome to another episode
of wrists of fury I'm Kelsey cook and
today I am joined by two of my best
friends and also the other co-host of
the self helpless podcast please give it
up for Delaney Fisher and Taylor
Tomlinson everywhere right now there's
no shame I love it I can't wait to play
yours we actually played each other for
the very first time like a month ago you
guys had never seen me play before what
was your first impression of that
terrifying
yeah I'm really scared of you now
terrified you're not intimidated by it
by trophies back here I've learned that
you have a wall of your trophies yeah
light bulb over here we're fine ideas
all we need I should've brought my
Speech and Debate trophies behind me
[ __ ] that would have been perfect is the
nerdy all-around yeah it's a real real
big dick moment I have here I just walk
in lay it out what's your foosball
experience I played you a month ago god
no no no yeah I played a little bit as a
kid and one time drunk in a bar okay
and I lost okay you guys both have very
competitive streaks like I feel like a
like Claude [ __ ] eyes out I've been
doing some prep work doing some wrist
exercises and things and ease exactly I
didn't know that's what we're supposed
to be doing
yeah I'm gonna go down to the boardwalk
and find a Rando to keep it profession
work I'm trained in here this is rocky
just going down just grabbing people in
your hoody throw that [ __ ] hood up
yeah all right well you taught me the
last time that we are not allowed to
spin no spin that's unfortunately that
was the first half of our strategy so I
forgot that part
you're lucky come on baby we're gonna
just do this at the same time and just
keep going down one that's all I got
bro please think of that oh you know you
know we got a was there any strategy
here on who was playing forward and who
is playing goalie um my heads bigger so
I wanted to be further from the camera
okay nice which at some pointers this
yeah I'm down to this is it so how it
works when you're playing doubles you
switch at each point or you can take a
timeout and switch you get huh oh my
gosh now I'm looking unprofessional I
think it's three timeouts per game so we
ask someone with more trophies you just
got me fired up I just like had smoke
come out of my nose like a dragon I will
destroy you guys
so we're gonna play this first game
we're just gonna play one two five you
guys are already advantaged by having
two of you we haven't had two on one
before so basically if we lose we suck
extra extra
yeah exactly that's how that math works
for this so you can you start it from
here what oh yeah so we get first ball
ladies first yeah put it right here
all right there's down let's go let's go
Oh Delaney I'm gonna go Delaney's moving
for no reason but I love it yeah Taylor
we got it
see that little dribble rush come in up
a little dribble little dribble is that
what it's called
yeah Taylor marry you come on we've got
a stagger and block the holes that's all
I think oh it's like a bullet I don't
understand you can't even see it going
in okay I was warming up okay all right
I got it
warm up no it's still it's your ball Oh
losers ball right do not defend us Oh
God the line is crumbling we got it oh
just even getting in the squares you go
oh oh just have her school on herself
somehow yeah could you do that okay
she's doing something weird she's doing
some weird
new news packaging just go as quick as
possible back and forth that was very
close okay millennia and I think my
strategy with you is to just like wear
you out so this is the strategy is if
somebody's doing crazy defense you have
15 seconds on your three bar so you can
just [ __ ] with them just like play with
the ball for 15 seconds and then do it
so think the longevity of the game by
the time we get to the fifth point
you're exhausted I think you might be a
psychopath okay you got the stand a
certain way because I'm doing a kind of
a lunge activity that's fine however
you're coming yeah I'm kind of squatting
I'm sure I look like Gollum I like put
on makeup for this I was like I should
look like I showered and then I got here
I'm just like no I did like Gaiman to
her trying to dribble okay no more doing
bits while we're playing yeah Delaney is
kind of why I know okay all right yeah
let's switch let's see what happens now
let's see alright here we go
I'm gonna pass over you put it close to
that guy yeah
mixed your pong your man you're a nerd I
love it who's chasing it up here almost
scored you guys alright it's hard being
competitive when you suck so bad
it's hard you can be competitive and
it's fun for you because you're like
haha like take a lap but I'm just angry
oh my god I've never seen you have you
so worked up I'll be honest I didn't
know how athletic this was until I
started more like are you guys like it's
like okay still us ball
so how come losers get the ball because
they take we feel bad for us it's like
it's and you know it helps you it's
based on if not based on who's losing
based on whoever just scored
I mean since I've scored four in a row
yeah it looks good but that wasn't cool
thing I've ever done it doesn't at the
same time my entire life please put that
on your highlight reel with like Conan
and then I turn it just right yeah and
then our face oh okay so I get the ball
Oh what what I didn't count all right it
didn't count so I just start with it
here yeah cuz like cuz I missed you
think I'm cheating I think I need a
cheap sort of cocky hands spin it's so
bad
I think you don't have I can't get it
out of here leave in yourself I really
want look at the rest see that nothing
happened there I just gave it to her oh
wow the need to spin it doesn't go away
alright something if it's fight for a
very long time it's really hard
Oh Mike see she doesn't with the force
of spinning it but all she doesn't do
this and I can't I'm so defeated right
now I don't even know how many this is
how we're starting our day yeah that's
the morning
that was five oh sorry nice I got half a
point cuz of her right I don't know what
that was thank you for an aisle yeah on
the Lord I wanted to incorporate a
little bit of like ourself helpless
podcast into this so these are gonna be
self-help based penalties so we're each
gonna draw a ball so you you guys draw
one I draw one okay so whoever decides
that they're gonna play goalie
you have to successfully paint your
nails while playing so you're gonna be
playing you're basically gonna release
yes and paint your nails you're gonna
rely heavily on your forward I thought
you had the handicap I have a handicap
to my god he gots way harder than you we
are playing against you but it's two
against one
there's a lot of levels to okay so what
if we are not even the nails yeah okay
okay so I have to make a smoothie while
I'm playing you guys what we're gonna
bring we have a smoothie cart
oh we're bringing a smoothie card over
there's gonna be a smoothie cart here I
have to try and make a smoothie and play
you guys are the same to buy so it's
gonna be total chaos I wants to try to
paint their nails and you do the nails
if you I mean like they could use them
anyway yeah I'm not gonna argue this was
just my nice way of like be like please
paint your nails delivered loud and
clear next round whoever loses has to
put on foundation yeah
Taylor concealer heard of it yeah next
round person FG leaves to get a haircut
I've set up an appointment
it's embarrassing to be around you okay
and I've been a part of - okay so you
guys prepare Delaney you have to paint
your nails I'm not going I have to make
a smoothie with this situation we've got
Hershey syrup we've got like there's
like M&Ms there's kale there's an onion
there's all kinds of [ __ ] here and see
the thing is the loser of everything has
to drink this movie what
I mean that's not fair talk about it
like oh and then the loser whoever that
might know are you regretting talking
[ __ ] to me veggies yeah got the onions
alright so let's see what happens
ready go yeah start painting your nails
[ __ ] oh wait oh because this is me
playing oh god this is me playing oh I
know I can yes I'm trying to help you
you're doing great Oh Oh fantastic oh no
I got you far away from them
oh my gosh I caught that was amazing oh
[Music]
I'm not drinking that [ __ ] start paying
your nails leave okay okay oh my gosh oh
she's okay she are that was like the
quickest score let's get it on there
[Music]
okay you guys have two points yeah where
I give up with this smoothie thing oh
you guys get a race yeah okay I get it
oh you get it cuz you lost I'm not used
to this okay okay ready she's gonna
start trying now that's a bad news okay
don't wear eyeliner get over there okay
okay all right it's hard to taste
victory
oh where are we we can Rita - okay we
did you okay okay we got it we got it
okay oh come on there's four minds of
men and you just oh oh okay oh god the
smell of onions and nail polish like
what chloroform's made of not a relaxing
Girl's Day no this is not what I had my
no I can't
Taylor don't worry my nails are freakin
done so I'm ready to roll okay don't
worry about it because uh because your
nails look great
Oh was that five no [ __ ] I was so ready
to just you have a comeback moment no
that was uh this meeting looks [ __ ]
awful oh my god looks like he didn't we
were driving a gravel road okay so you
guys now get to get coached by my Hall
of Fame foosball champion mom yes time
with her and get some tips things so bad
really bad do I hold it it's okay look
at your mother mom look what happened to
Delaney's nail she had to paint her
nails while playing me alright so can
you give them some coaching tips oh my
god Oh Mike mother oh my gosh look at
you guys they're always behind me
Christmas is like look at my trophies oh
look at my truck oh my god she's got
about three times as many as you do you
kills huh oh boy yeah yeah she's a
badass she's a bad [ __ ] so are you
gonna hear the tips that she's giving us
yeah oh so it's not a secret charity I
already know every time
okay really in the pregame get outta
here he closed her ears you hold the
phone here we go okay you're in timeout
I'm in time to get out of here do you
have any tips for us we have two people
not school we try to school that's
actually that's very good okay so we'll
try to fake her out a little bit lots of
fake outs this round okay so and if none
of those tips work kelsey is very
allergic to peppermint right just like
it'll be like she'll have to go to the
hospital I am you're my mom you should
know these things
thank you so much that was very helpful
that was good we're gonna crush it okay
so you got some coaching tips from my
mama and we're gonna play two ball this
is the the last round
sudden death so how to ball works is
that we each start with a ball we go one
two three go okay and you have to score
both balls in order to get a point so if
I score a ball and you guys score a ball
it's a wash and the first person to get
three points win and if you don't win
may I remind you you're drinking an
onion ginger M&M kale chocolate syrup
cranberries
that sounds it's probably really
expensive some are not exactly you know
have I ever told you that you're a real
[ __ ] ha ha had no idea why you feel nice
until today oh yeah I'm a different
person I'm sorry I'm really sorry ok
ready go 1 2 3 oh I'm going left but
pretending to go right faking you out
like your mom said okay that was like
there was one ball I don't even want to
acknowledge what this happened I was
just not not can we edit that part out
yeah no 1 2 3 Oh God I honestly don't
even know how that occurred okay go real
fast strategy I got your back don't
worry we're doing great Taylor why don't
you go yep nice I've never cared about
anything more did your goalie just do
that yeah I just from all the way did
you guys have breakfast yet cuz well
that's probably [ __ ] 1 2 3
[Laughter]
well my mom pick me up for good JA he's
critical I did it was the most
condescending thing universe' won I'm so
thank God yeah
no handicap Delaney's scored honors
[ __ ] score I have never seen either
of you so out of breath
this is okay don't really exercise these
are muscles onto themselves yeah there
is no machine at the gym no you go in
like yeah it's like a t-rex boxing like
this is a hole you have to do this over
and over I'm gonna come here every day
and I'm gonna stay here like this
rematch
ready for some heavy time
oh my oh that does not sound good
I think that might be breaking the
blenders yeah what if it's like the best
movie you've ever tasted
[Music]
no I feel like right now a [ __ ] we did
score after all it looks like when you
think your periods over but there's a
little bit like why would you make it so
much worse for yourself what I it's
already bad and uh this is like a
sleepover you regret getting invited to
yeah this is like a Johnny Knoxville oh
my gosh oh my god oh god it looks like
it do they make you do this in like
championship games yeah are they this
cruel to okay cheers it up I we did like
the ghost of Christmas future right now
oh my god describe down don't oh my god
I can't even look at you I can't even
look at you what's it taste like like
spicy vomit how did everyone I couldn't
swallow it because I love you guys so
much and you are two of my best friends
I won't make you drink anymore this is
so bad you've won enough Oh gracious oh
just like know what it was it'll bond us
all closer together why don't you know
what no you can't drive from the buy one
all right you guys where can people
follow you
Delanie fisher calm at Dulaney fisher my
website it's tea time comedy calm
tea time comedy on Instagram Taylor
Tomlinson on Twitter perfect you can
follow me at Kelsey cook comedy on
instagram at Kelsey cook on Twitter
Kelsey cook calm for tour dates and
please subscribe to this self helpless
Podcast yes for our podcast on the all
things comedy Network and we love doing
it very much
so all right I love you guys Cheers
see you guys next time
thank you guys for watching another
episode of erisa fury be sure to pick up
your official and Rissa Fury shirt they
are buttery soft they feel like dolphin
skin they're amazing be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
can you pull my pants up because my
nails are still wet yes thank you